some cheese miss yes please thank you
just tell me when to stop
yeah
[Music]
I'll tell you when I want you to stop
okay
[Music]
oh you guys want pizza for lunch yes
okay I can't have pizza I'm lactose
intolerant
oh that's awful
yeah that's how you know it's good you
really put cheese on everything don't
you
[Music]
cheese on cheese can I change to that
can i cheese today and would you like
cheese with that ah Jake crazy boy ha do
i watch cheese bed you crazy see that
pick up I'm gonna name my first daughter
breathe you think I can name our kid man
trigger yeah yeah what kind of cheese do
you have so miss Brunson you are in
excellent health oh thank goodness
oh and we also found these source of
your stomach issues okay what is it did
you know you were lactose intolerant
your blood has a deficiency and lactase
is the buy just dairy
[Music]
what I just had the worst dream
it started out so relatable what is this
geez what said you wanted some peas [ __ ]
geez pressing goals what do you think I
mean Wow okay this is not my apartment